[Music]
with update 1.8 point one coming out on
the 12th of April I thought why not
quickly run through what we should be
expecting to see firstly we're getting
two new legendary difficulty missions
Amherst apartment and Grand Central
Station I'm pretty stoked about this
legendary missions offer the greatest
difficulty in the game as far as PvE
goes resistance is good but not really
meant for solo play as the difficulty
steps up a little too quickly I find the
resistance missions a really good test
for new builds and also team
collaboration shortly after the patch is
released one of the new global events
blackout will become active I'll try and
get another video out about this before
the 12th then in may who will be seeing
another new global event onslaught there
are no further details on the released 8
yet we sort of expected this as soon as
the optimization station concept was
brought out in 1.8 it became apparent
that we needed more ways of getting
division tech especially since the main
way of getting it right now is through
the dark zone and a large portion of the
player vests weren't into this area now
we'll be able to get the division tech
through daily missions like the combat
assignments crafting survival and duct
zone quests each of these will reward
you 25 diptych weekly missions like the
open world assignment and underground
assignment will reward you with a
hundreds of tech each if you're a season
pass holder you'll now get a hundred
division tech in the supply drops that
drop twice a month there has been a
classified gear cache added to the
special vendor this guarantees one
classified gear piece from the entire
class fight gear glue pool I'm not 100%
certain on the cost of this cache but it
looks like they'll be somewhere in the
vicinity of 2500 Phoenix credits based
on the pts you won't be able to buy up
large or anything but this does add a
new way of getting classified pieces the
basic cash from the GE vendor the one
that costs nine hundred GE credits has
been removed instead this vendor will
now sell individual caches
her classified gear said for each global
event so for example if striker is
available in the current global event
there will be a strike a cache available
for purchase there guarantees an item
from the striker set removed premium
vendor exotics from the open world loop
pool and exotic caches all exotics added
to the open world bosses this should
mean that farming for exotics gets a
little bit easier
no more will ever getting multiple
cassadee's per week just a quick tip if
you're not already doing it hold on to
your exotic caches until the update
drops and then open them up when their
changes have been implemented for a
better chance of getting what you
actually want classified drop rates have
been increased in all locations the
legendary missions now have a 20% chance
to give classified gear as a reward at
the completion of the mission season
pass supply drops now have a temp same
chance to drop classified gear survival
caches now has a roughly 10% chance to
drop classified gear it's not going to
be raining classifieds or anything but
the existing ways of getting classified
gear has basically had their drop rates
doubled in most cases and with the
addition of legendary missions and
survival caches now dropping them we're
certainly going to be seeing them a lot
more often they're doing this to help
close that gap between the hardcore
players already have everything and the
more casual and new players as per usual
there's a bunch of bug fixes that have
been included in this update I won't go
over all of them
most are quite specific and win exactly
game breaking I'll leave a link to the
full one point 8.1 patch notes in the
description but the following are
probably the most important bug fixes to
take note of
[Music]
this video will be more of a reminder to
a lot of you but I know there is a
number of you who don't troll through
the forums and read it every day so this
is probably a little more useful to you
there has been no exact release date on
the new blackout global event just that
it will start shortly after the patch is
released as I said I'll do my best to
put out a video soon that will cover
everything we know about this event and
what builds will get the most out of it
as a side note a couple of weeks ago I
mentioned that in preparation for the
division 2
I started up a character on PC I'm now
about 60 hours in I'm still a little
light on gear but I have managed to get
a couple of classified sets completed
it's been a little tough gearing up on
the PC you will still maintaining a
character on the Xbox as this is where
all my recording comes from the idea is
that I'd like to start recording from
the PC version of the game because the
graphics quality I'm getting is
considerably better although I'm
predominantly a solo player there are a
number of aspects to this game that are
best experienced in a team and when it
comes to the content creation side of
things and quite often needing some
assistance from other players to test
things out I need to build a crew I was
going to check out the community discord
channel but first I thought I'd check
and see if there are any subsets will be
interested I don't care about skill
level and I'm quite happy to help out
with your builds and other things if
needed this is really starting to sound
like a personal add screw it let's run
with it in all seriousness I'm not after
hardcore gamers just anyone who loves
the game and can enjoy it for what it is
the only thing that can be a little bit
awkward is my time zone I'm totally not
desperate I'm just putting it out there
call me if you keen [ __ ] me an email
Cheers seriously
[Music]